vamos a tener una reunión familiar así
que necesitamos acomodar mesas cuadradas
como estas en el patio de nuestra casa
como nuestro patio es alargado las
acomodaremos formando una línea se
acomodó cuatro mesas cuántas personas se
pueden sentar alrededor consideremos que
por cada lado de la mesa cabe una
persona en este caso se podrían sentar
diez personas si nos llegan todos los
invitados a la reunión y solo serán seis
personas para comer cuántas mesas
necesito acomodar pausa el vídeo para
que intentes averiguarlo para resolver
esta pregunta vamos a determinar cuántas
personas se pueden sentar dependiendo de
las mesas que acomodemos con una sola
mesa tenemos cuatro lugares con dos
mesas tenemos seis lugares que son los
que necesitamos para las seis personas
que van a comer pero podemos seguir
agregando mesas con tres mesas tenemos
ocho lugares y con cuatro mesas tenemos
diez
creo que ya te estás dando cuenta de
cómo van a aumentar
lugar es una mesa es igual a 4 lugares 2
es igual a 6 3 es igual a 8 y con cuatro
mesas tenemos 10 lugares
cuántos lugares tendremos con cinco
mesas como puedes ver nuestros lugares
van aumentando de dos en dos por cada
mesa que agregamos así que podemos
resolver cuántos lugares tendremos con
muchas mesas sin tener que dibujar las
todas como regla general podemos decir
que por cada mesa tendremos dos lugares
más los dos lugares de las orillas
así que si llega todo un ejército a
comer a nuestra casa ya puedes saber
cuántas mesas de acomodar para que todos
tengan un lugar sólo asegúrate de
contarlos muy bien